We're asked to simplify this
huge, long expression here. x
to the third plus 3x minus 6--
that's in parentheses-- plus
negative 2x squared
plus x minus 2.
And then minus the quantity
3x minus 4.
So a good place to start, we'll
just rewrite this and
see if we can eliminate the
parentheses in this step.
So let's just start
at the beginning.
We have the x to the third
right over there.
So x to the third and then
plus 3x-- I'll do that in
pink-- plus 3x.
And then we have a minus 6.
And we don't have to put the
parentheses around there,
those don't really
change anything.
And we don't have to even write
these-- do anything with
these parentheses.
We can eliminate them.
Just because there's a positive
sign out here we
don't have to distribute
anything.
Distributing a positive
sign doesn't do
anything to these numbers.
So then plus, we have a
negative 2x squared.
So this term right here
is negative 2x
squared, or minus x squared.
And then we have a plus x.
We have a plus x.
Then we have a minus 2.
Then we have a negative sign
times this whole expression.
So we're going to have to
distribute the negative sign.
So it's a positive 3x, but
it's being multiplied by
negative 1.
So it's really a negative 3x.
So minus 3x, then you have a
negative-- you can imagine
this is a negative 1 implicitly
out here-- negative
1 times negative 4.
That's a positive 4.
So plus 4.
Now, we could combine
terms of similar
degree, of the same degree.
Now, first we have an x to the
third term and I think it's
the only third degree term here,
because we have x being
raised to the third power.
So let me just rewrite
it here.
We have x to the third.
And now let's look at our x
squared terms. Looks like we
only have one.
We only have this
term right here.
So we have minus 2x squared.
And then what about
our x terms?
We have a 3x plus an
x minus a 3x again.
So that 3x minus the 3x would
cancel out, and you're just
left with an x.
So plus x.
And then finally our constant
terms. Negative 6
minus 2 plus 4.
Negative 6 minus 2 gets
us to negative 8.
Plus 4 is negative 4.
And we are done.
We have simplified
the expression.
Now we just have a four
term polynomial.